Hi, I'm Chris Manning here to answer your
questions on artificial intelligence.
[Music] Here are a couple
of AI-generated questions.
Considering the rapid progress in NLP what
key factors and actions should the community
prioritize for responsible and ethical AI
language model deployment and development?
Well it's really good to know that
the AI systems are also thinking
about what's important for responsible
and ethical AI language model deployment.
So, there are lots of things to think about there.
We certainly want systems that don't exhibit
conventional gender biases or ethnic stereotypes.
The fact of the matter is that all of the current
large language models do exhibit those problems.
In part it's because these models are just trained
on a lot of historical data from the world.
You know, one of the the things that human
beings are better at is having in their
head how they think the world should be
rather than just knowing how the world has
been and having statistics based on that.
But there are also details of the machine learning
models where they tend to emphasize majority
cases and forget about the minority cases.
So we should be working out how to build
models that do a better job of that. But we should
also be trying to get data from different sources
so it represents different groups.
And we should have the preferences
of different groups involved in the
evaluation of models. finding their
weak spots, teaching them how to behave.
So a couple of people at Stanford have
been involved in this idea of jury learning,
Professor Michael Bernstein and his students,
and the idea there is that there isn't sort of
one right answer to how you should behave in
many contexts, that different subgroups
of people have different Impressions.
And so you actually want to represent
a jury of your peers and how different
people feel about things, and so lots
of things to explore in those areas.
AI system asks: what are some of
the most promising and exciting
real world applications of NLP that you
foresee emerging in the next few years?
Uh, tons! So I think we're going to see a lot
more NLP systems being deployed very successfully
everywhere. So a lot of websites already have
a little AI assistant in the bottom corner.
I think we're going to see a new generation
of ones powered by large language models
which really work much more fluently.
I think we're going to see much more
use of conversational assistants. So you're
thinking about how to word an email to your
boss, or you're not quite sure what
you should say to your boyfriend.
It turns out that you can
get advice, drafting help,
suggestions of what to say from a large language
model that are actually useful these days.
You know, I think there's just a whole world
of ways that we can use these models because
our world is so language based and that we're
all just sort of exploring what some of the
possibilities are.
[Music]